this was our first free thing under the
Maltese presidency starting with the
reverse charge mechanism especially the
Eastern European countries feel that in
the region there is vet fraud the rest
of the countries asked the Commission to
prepare a proposal it's giving a chance
for a pilot project and give it their
location to a country which suffers from
this fraud to try that out however
without any negative spillovers on the
other countries last but not least is
the AI B's proposal on the resilience
initiative about investment in North
Africa we intend to extend this into our
informal echofon which were going to
host in the first week of April the way
to approach economic migration is by
addressing the economic imbalances
between the North and the South today
finance ministers agreed on the main
documents of the 2017 a European
semester EU economy is recovering we
expect all EU member states to grow this
year echofon also adopted the guidance
under euro area recommendations those
member states which are an excessive
deficit procedure or should continues a
convergence towards medium-term
budgetary objectives while those member
states which are already all over
performing on the medium-term budgetary
objectives could use their fiscal space
to stimulate investment we also
discussed today is a state of play on
ago sessions in a basel committee we
want to reach agreement which works for
everyone which makes European banks
stronger without hampering the funding
of European economic recovery